the surface pro 4 arrives three years
the day after the launch of the original
surface that machine was a pure hybrid
PC where the keyboard snaps off so you
can use it as a tablet in those three
years the hybrid approach has clearly
emerged the future of Windows mobility
so Microsoft is probably right to
attempt to corner the market this new
surface has seen some improvements under
the hood and the touch screens
resolution has been boosted by about 25%
while there are some performance and
utility hiccups and while the removable
keyboard remains underwhelming there's
plenty of power packed into the sub to
pound machine the new screen in
particular is dazzling and the speakers
are powerful too making the surface pro
4 an impressive platform for video and
multimedia content pricing starts at
$899 and goes all the way up to 2600 $99
you do get a surface pin in the box for
free but you still have to purchase the
type cover separately for 130 dollars
this new surface doesn't reinvent last
year's model but it does offer
thoughtful refinements to the surface
platform and that's probably a good
aside as any that Microsoft knows what
it's doing